the internal watchdog of the justice
department says it will investigate the
trump administration's seizure
of communication records of two
democratic members of the house
intelligence committee
the requests were made by former
attorneys general jeff sessions and
william barr in their aggressive
investigation to locate the source of
leaks
about trump's 2016 campaign ties to
russia
jeff begays reports the sea's phone logs
date back to 2017
and 2018 as the house intelligence
committee's russia investigation was
underway
president trump wanted to know where the
leaks were coming from
justice department prosecutors secretly
subpoenaed
phone information from apple for
democrats eric swalwell and adam schiff
and people close to them including a
minor it's a
another terrible abuse of the justice
department another shattering of the
norms
since watergate schiff had been a
frequent target of the president
and shifty schiff how about this guy
attorney general william barr
continued the leak investigation and
stumbled when asked by then senator
kamala harris
if the president or anyone at the white
house had ordered him to
open an investigation i wouldn't i
wouldn't
uh yes or no
could you could you repeat that question
i don't know i wouldn't say suggest
hinted i don't know former republican
attorney general alberto gonzalez says
the phone record subpoenas
are troubling so based on what you know
was was that contrary to doj policy
what is being reported is certainly if
not contrary to policy
certainly inconsistent with the finest
traditions of the department
the inspector general will investigate
the doj's use of subpoenas to apple and
microsoft
not only to obtain the cell phone and
email records of members of congress
but also of the news media in connection
with recent leak investigations
also democrats in the senate are
demanding that former
ag's william barr and jeff sessions
testify on capitol hill for cbs this
morning saturday
jeff begaye is in washington